bailey i gotta tell you you know it's
been such a joy watching you in this
role and
seeing you playing a character who's
pregnant nobody wants your pregnant
tragic ass here
well i'm not going anywhere
in fact i'm gonna be spirit queen
she's got my vote what was that
experience like how did your boyfriend
react how did your intercept react to
seeing you with the bum
yeah i definitely sent him some photos
what did he say
he said you look really pretty
good
showing all of his you know mates and
his tour people he's a good one he's a
good one how was that it was so fun it
was like i was super everyone who anyone
who knows me knows like i can't wait to
be a mom one day and so like for me it
was like the best test run ever i
realized what jeans i don't want to wear
i realized work clothes do not work when
i'm pregnant like it was actually it was
it was like a master class for the
future back pain like my ribs kind of
went out of place from the pressure of
the pregnancy stomach so i got it i got
a good taste of it i love that you just
asked what his reaction yeah the call to
my dad was a was a funny one when i told
him i got it and then when i said i'm
pregnant on it
oh
oh
well that's inter that's new for you
it is but you know i look i i've been so
fortunate to grow up in this business i
love what i do i'm entering you know my
my early 20s
um and i'm in the middle of it right now
and and this role was the first time i
feel like i actually got to strip
everything that was bailey and dive into
this and so it actually feels the most
vulnerable i've i feel the most
vulnerable i've ever felt sharing a
character um in my career and so
uh yeah imaging means a lot to me and
and i think all of us feel very very
much the same with who we were able to
bring to life and chandler you too you
know a lot of your fans come from the
disney world what does it mean to you to
be able to do a very grown-up part like
this one uh you know i i feel very
vulnerable i think is a really strong
word for it um you know being in this
space now because
i've done a lot of work with disney and
and i love
the the that demographic that fan base i
love the young kids who get so
emotionally invested in those characters
and so now to step into the world of hbo
max where you know the the creative
license is limitless and you can really
you can push the envelope you can um you
know get really intimately involved in
these characters lives it's definitely a
bit scary it's new it's different and
i'm just i'm really excited for this
next chapter of my life
and um you know it's been it's been
pretty incredible i think bayley and i
we've we've shared a lot of uh or a very
similar experience having been you know
in the industry at a very young age and
and being in a different
um demographic and now moving into
something like this and so it was a lot
of leaning on each other and uh you know
asking each other's opinions on things
and
and being there for each other so it was
really beautiful mallory this question's
for you my hat is off to you my girl
you're pulling double duty you're
playing twins principal clinton mrs
beasley
karen
did he recognize you he completely
thought i was you how is that going for
you how do you switch your brain to to
know what you're doing today in this
specific scene it's
it's such a fun challenge
switching between is actually it's it's
not as difficult as it seems it there
are some days where i would go and i
would start as karen and then we would
switch and i would be kelly but i any
scene where both twins are present i had
a twin double her name was alex o'shea
and she's such a talented actress and in
my mind she's also karen and kelly like
we did all these scenes together so i
always had someone to play off of who
was wearing cali's clothes while i was
dressed up as karen and then there's
like very easy external differences like
karen wears heels and kelly doesn't and
that affects my posture and just little
tiny
stuff like karen throws her brow and
kelly doesn't you know so i had a lot of
things
to grab on to to ground me to be like
okay this is this is who we are right
now um but it was certainly it's a
little bit of whiplash but it was
oh my gosh so fun those were my favorite
days on set is when i got to be both of
them
[Music]
you